I have rage today I'm so sorry sweetie
no no no but I just get he Brown of rage
inside me and the simplest thing just
lets it off like it's usually traffic do
you honk no and then she's like dude
relax that's what she's she's there you
know and I feel bad that she has to take
the brunt of my [ __ ] insanity what
you have rage well that kind of road
rage is the person sitting next means I
was like quaintly just chill out and
it's like are you the one are you calm
down oh you're like are you on your
phone yeah yeah yeah I can't deal with
it I have rage I Rolo rage you do yeah
do you lash out on other people or just
just to yourself um well - ever ever is
like immediately around me okay I have a
lot of self-doubt all the time yeah so
that's cool though cuz we might win the
race what does that what'd he mean
because we're like I need over know
about the right I mean well the race of
life yeah why but like I feel like the
thing is like if you expect things to go
well and they don't they never will
so I've almost like it's a good luck
charm to be pessimistic that's wanted
yeah I go like this I go you know what
this is gonna fail and if it does don't
like um yeah exactly right exactly what
happens when it's a success and it's
even worse when it's a successor like oh
my god it's a success
that's just like me yeah baby she's like
my sister we might be related yeah yeah
when its success and then it's like I
don't know how to hide it like hide the
doubt after you know I don't know how to
hide the even like you know the the low
self-esteem even if I'm on the set right
and they go that was a great take I'm
and I want to go I should go like this I
should go yeah I did great I love that
one but that's not what happened
you did a great job I got I did that one
word I said I don't think was clear
uh-huh it was clear we got it no nope
like it's always weird I have to make it
weird
I can't just go accept it they that they
have the take and move on why would they
pull it on [ __ ] do you feel good inside
even worse you'll always come home I
didn't like me they didn't like me well
do you feel well do you why do you think
they like you he has an alcoholics all
right because I'm addict sense because
I'm a drug addict this is what I am this
and I've always been like this as a kid
if I walk into a party and this is
narcissism right and self-centeredness I
already immediately think that everyone
in the party hates me right so when I'm
on a set and I'm acting and I see video
village where all the producers and
directors are all huddle in a tent they
go like this action I'll go cut and I'll
sit there like this and in my peripheral
I'll see them and they're talking and I
think that they're saying the worst [ __ ]
about me some heroes I'm sure is
available right in my head and then they
come up to me a great job we're gonna
move on I go you deception
it's deception I gotta play better
playing in shadows yeah cuz I feel like
it's feels easy a people lie to you yeah
you know but it's unhealthy it's really
I mean you sound like you're all
paranoid is you you kill the paranoid
you killed that [ __ ] oh god why did you
just say that why oh he's make you feel
shy you know I feel great thank you
thank you kill it too
where is not nice yeah and then
[Music]